hi there today I have a special guest
it's my guide to the Persian language to
Iranian history and culture Sahara whom
I have mentioned before and I wanted to
have an interview with her to talk about
the role that she has had in my Persian
language learning but remember if you
enjoy these videos please subscribe
click on the bell for notifications and
if you enjoy you know if you're on a
podcast service please leave a comment
so hello Sahara hi hello Steve how are
you
I'm fine thank you so normally when we
meet of course we speak Persian so it's
fun for me it's much more relaxing to
speak English however speaking English
is not going to improve my Farsi so
first of all can you tell us where you
live okay what's your educational
background your professional background
and so forth
uh of course So currently I'm living in
Iran
uh in
north of Iran actually so yeah but I'm
from Shiraz you know this video
yeah so my educational background I have
a master's degree in Translation studies
and I have translated a couple of books
so I've been a professional translator
in Iran
and yeah it's been a pleasure it's me
tutoring
urgent View
okay so and I wanted to have this
conversation to talk about how we have
worked together first of all today is
the last day of my sort of 90 Day
Challenge three months of Persian uh and
we are going to have a conversation in
Persian
first let me make it very clear that I
have focused on Persian for three months
that doesn't mean that I started Persian
three months ago in fact if I look at my
statistics I first started dabbling in
Persian in uh June of 2018 and then if I
look at my statistics I see that I get
very active around August of 2020 and
there are sort of Peaks and valleys
because I have been sort of playing with
Persian at the same time as I'm playing
with Arabic a little bit of Turkish yeah
and so I've had a lot of fun with it I
haven't been focused but for the last
three months I was focused so what I
would like to discuss with you today is
first of all uh the role I want to talk
a little bit about the role you have
played and how you have found this
experience because it's different from
your background and then talk a little
bit about how you think I have done in
these three months that I've been
focused on Percy FRC so uh first of all
you know you I think before we connected
you were already teaching Persian is
that correct uh yes
yes I was also teaching Persian yeah
right but the way we have worked
together is a little bit different
because you have created so much content
for link starting from many stories to
getting your friends to talk about
themselves mostly women who have you
know a pastry shop or uh interior
designer or different people in
different areas of activity and some
guys as well interested in musical
instruments and you get sort of a range
of
Iranian modern Iranian culture through
these interviews and then you of course
created courses on history on on food
and other things and then more recently
you have found
podcasts that are of interest to me and
are at my level so how have you gone
about like how has seen from your end of
it I'll talk about what it's been like
for me but what's what has it been like
for you at your end of this experience
yeah so well uh when when we started
actually this journey uh at first I so
after a couple of sessions I actually
realized that yeah you are interested in
history and culture in like maybe
politics everyone and so we actually uh
we were mostly focusing on the topics
that were interesting to you and so
around these topics you like to know
about the culture I found some people
and talk to them so there were some
natural conversations with people and so
you use them as your lessons and you got
to know culture uh also about the food
about Persian Cuisine and about many
things we actually had the topics about
ethnicities in Iran and yes yes yeah
yeah and many the history of Iran which
uh you're very much interested so it was
actually very interesting
because I was I was always looking for
the content that you enjoyed and at the
same time I was learning a lot it was
kind of reviewing everything for me too
I remember when I Was preparing the
history of Iran I went through all this
content and I made some summaries to
provide them for you so it was very
interesting to me too and then after
that we found those YouTube channels uh
yeah so we also use the YouTube channels
which have transcriptions and uh the
podcast yeah the most recently we uh
worked on the podcast which was again
about uh history and culture
so my question is first of all the 26
episodes in the history of Iran that you
created for us at link is phenomenal and
I still go back to it because there's so
many words there that I still don't know
and as you know you read about history
and whatever you read you forget and
then you go back and you read it again
and slowly it becomes clearer and you
start to separate you know the safavid
dynasty from the sasanian dynasty
because otherwise you get the more
confused uh but then more recently you
have so first of all I can appreciate
that you did a lot of research in order
to put this together in 26 balanced
episodes with circling questions and so
forth so that was a lot of work but I
appreciated it but then recently you
have found both podcasts and YouTube
videos with transcripts and that's such
a tremendous service because for me to
go searching the internet for you know
Persian language podcasts that have
transcripts that are on issues of of you
know our interest to me and and where
the voice is pleasant and the sound is
pleasant and so you do this for me
that's a tremendous service how do you
find these resources
it's not very easy to find the content
in Persian which also has the text the
transcripts right yeah so and also it's
really interesting to you that's too uh
yeah so I I actually searched some
keywords for some yeah look for some
keywords on the YouTube and then of
course there are there is one popular
podcast in Iran so and that uh first of
all we had some some of the their videos
had transcripts and you remember at
first when they didn't have the those
podcasts on YouTube we actually uh uh we
were using their episodes and we talked
to them and we actually asked for
permission and we use those accounts oh
yes
yeah yeah yeah so and then after that
put many videos on YouTube which was
very easier for us to to use the content
about the the podcast the recent podcast
epidemic books actually
it's important yeah you couldn't find
this because it's important to search
those keywords in Persian and you know
looking for the content included by a
native speaker it's much easier than for
a learner of course yeah and it's a
tremendous service I think this is the
role of a language teacher is to be a
guide a guide that not only finds first
of all figures out what the learner's
interested in and then knows where to
find it and and sort of introduces like
the stuff you've given me recently where
they talk about you know uh national
identity in Iran that's so interesting
it's like I'm eavesdropping on a
conversation amongst Iranians about
their own you know ethnic identity uh
and a number of other these they're just
it's just outstanding yeah and I'm sure
in other languages the same kinds of
material whether it be in Polish or
Chinese or It's gotta exist somewhere
but it's very hard for the learner to
find these because you come up you go to
the the website and it's all in their
writing system and it's it's just you're
not used to it you know so you don't
know where to go so that's a tremendous
tremendous service yeah yeah it's of
course it's difficult for you to find
those yeah uh yeah and uh so now what I
think what we might do is we'll speak in
Persian now so I gotta try to switch my
brain and then at the end of it maybe
you can talk a little bit about how you
find that I have improved or maybe I
haven't improved uh just in these last
three months that I have been focusing
on uh frsi okay of course sure yeah okay
[Music]
first is
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
Orlando
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
lizard
okay it is happening
foreign
[Music]
begum and and benazariman alone shot
um
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
best yeah
okay
okay so I mean it's hard to to sort of
have an artificial to some extent
artificial conversation but I have to
tell you that between the material that
you have provided me that I have I so
much enjoy reading and listening to uh
and then twice a week conversations I
feel so much more comfortable in my
Farsi than I did three months ago of
course of course and you're more
confident when using the words using the
structures yeah I can feel that so I
remember that before uh you you knew
some words but you didn't actually use
them correctly or you actually hesitated
when using them but then gradually I I
realized that you are using them without
me mentioning those uh words so it means
that there's something like some
patterns as you always say we're formed
in your brain and then you just realize
how to use those words just by
practicing
well you know it's funny you you start
to understand words you still confuse
words
you tend to confuse this word with that
word and you can't really distinguish
them and but over time it's as if these
words sort of slowly become clearer and
clearer and at some point you're able to
recall them naturally whereas up to that
point you're trying to recall the word
you have sort of this vague recollection
of the word but you can't really produce
it and the only way this starts to
happen is if you have enough continuous
exposure to the language and and
listening but also reading reading is so
important because when you're reading
and I read an article about this when
you're reading you're actually
sub-vocalizing so that in the brain
apparently reading is closer to speaking
than listening when you're listening
you're not producing the language in any
way but when you're reading because
reading is something that's very recent
from an evolutionary perspective I mean
most people never read throughout
history people didn't read it's only
recently that people started reading
only in the last 200 years and only a
small percentage of people ever read so
that it's it's a new thing for the brain
and the brain is actually creating the
language when when we're reading so
reading is very powerful people don't
realize it but but the listening is of
course much easier to do because I can
do it whenever I want yeah well thank
you um yeah go ahead yeah and I
I'm sure that you're trying
I don't want to talk too much because
we're still playing around with
different ways of doing it but but yeah
and recreating the sentences that's but
that'll come that's still a few weeks
away but ever continuing to work on
things so that you know that working
with our interesting content content of
Interest which I tend to do in sentence
mode because it's easier to go sentence
by sentence rather than a whole page of
text and now I have this ability to
reconstitute the sentence that I've been
studying and and all of that is getting
me into the language and of course our
twice weekly conversation so it's
important to have a variety of
activities but I think it's really key
to have content of interest and that's
where I think the role of Someone Like
You who is a a language guy more than a
language teacher uh I think that's just
so important so I thank you very much
for introducing us through all these
things it's been a pleasure and I even
enjoy that actually myself too thank you
okay and I haven't given up I may do
Arabic for three months but I'll be back
to Persian as well so oh okay thank you
I will keep sending
oh please do for a please dude please do
yeah okay well thank you very much and I
hope this was of interest to my
listeners as well thank you thank
you thank you thank you bye-bye bye